[Musik]
wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns hier
in unserer kleinen süßen mein verfällt
meine lieben freunde wir stehen hier auf
unserer in der letzten folge gebauten
kleinen yacht und an diesem haus hier
müssen wir auch ganz kurz reichte markt
geben weiter bauen dafür muss ich jedoch
noch mal ganz kurz eben zu unserer insel
laufen können
[Musik]
ich war
ja
das will ich jetzt machen das ist
nämlich auch schon das erste to do was
für heute auf unserer riesigen
to-do-liste steht und zu ich weiß aber
ich hatte bisher noch keine wir müssen
uns demnächst echt mal ein paar dinge
kümmern die schon seit monaten auf
unserer für do liste stehen
zuvor nämlich allerdings das eisenerz
hieraus ein bisschen kohle und auch noch
sein denn wir benötigen nicht nur glas
für die situation dort achtung einmal
verträgt ich brauche eben auch noch kurz
ein bisschen glas wir brauchen nämlich
nicht nur das glas für die strandhaus
villa wo ich mir noch mal ganz kurz eben
ein bisschen schwarzes glas machen muss
acht stück sollten auf jeden fall
reichen sondern wir benötigen auch noch
glas führt das was ihr schon im titel
sieht nämlich heute fertig also hier
vorne erst mal die golderze reihen da
passen zwei kohle dann perfekt hier
vorne das eisenerz dann müssen danach
kohle rein zack und hier unten machen
wir nochmal sand rein da sollten drei
stück reichen und hier auch nochmal 16
da frag ich jetzt einmal den rest rein
den glatten sandstein kann ich auch
direkt schon mitnehmen zusammen mit ein
bisschen erde die ich nämlich auch noch
benötige die sollte ich glaube ich auch
hier vorne drin haben perfekt erde erde
erde erde und wir benötigen eigentlich
auch noch gras die sache ist allerdings
dass ich glaube ich kein gras mehr habe
und leider auch meine behutsamkeit
spitzhacke ja kaputt gegangen ist von
daher müssen wir noch mal ganz kurz
schauen ob da vielleicht eine neue
verzaubern können effizienz haben wir
darauf nur eisen spitzhacke generell ich
kann theoretisch mal diese beiden
einfach kurz zusammenpackt dann habe ich
eine neue und dann kann ich mal schauen
ob wir dort vorne behutsamkeit drauf
bekommen
die sache ist dass wir immer noch
unseren videothek ein bisschen
hochleveln müssen so dass er uns halt
eventuell irgendwann auch bücher traden
kann
da wird mir auch und in die kommentare
geschrieben luca ist macht eigentlich
deutlich mehr sinn wenn man das ist hier
nicht ihre effizienz vier haltbarkeit 2
und effizienz 1
die scheiße mir wurde auf jeden fall
geschrieben dass es eigentlich deutlich
mehr sinn macht wenn ich den
bibliothekar nicht immer hoch level von
zeit zu zeit sondern das ganze einfach
so mache dass ich immer einen neuen
villiger dem beruf bibliothekar gebe ich
brauche mich erst mal ganz kurz die hoch
und kümmern mich jetzt erst mal ganz
kurz um das hier denn damit dass sie
nämlich fertig hier vorne kann ich den
glatten sandstein wieder abbauen das
waren nur zur verhältnis der achtung der
gavi nichtig gewesen wäre dass wir
absoluter wahnsinn gewesen und jetzt
noch ein mal eben kurz hier hoch um die
ecke gelaufen und dann können wir hier
vorne auf die erde direkt wieder abbauen
wir müssen demnächst auf jeden fall die
komplette einrichtung hier von unserer
standorte da noch machen das hier bleibt
natürlich auch nicht so dass wir auch
noch alles ganz neu sind hier oben kommt
dann wohnzimmer hin und so weiter und so
fort wir brauchen auch noch hier für den
beton oder ist das hier nie das ist keys
oder ja das ist klartext oder ja das ist
keys warum fehlten dann ihr einer ist
aber auch egal wir können trio realität
theoretisch vom einfachen hier nehmen
sich nämlich hier denke ich einfach mal
so ein bisschen erde hin das ist ja
nicht ständig steht allerdings drauf
dann können wir den hellgrauen trocken
mit anpacken sie hat sich ein bisschen
kleiner aus auf jeden fall die fackel
hier das kommt demnächst natürlich auch
noch alles weg das müssen wir alles mal
in zukunft irgendwann machen allerdings
sieht es ja bereits im titel
eingeblendet wir kümmern uns heute hier
darum um den tunnel und fragt euch jetzt
wahrscheinlich luca warum baust du das
hier vorne ab man doch gar keinen sinn
mehr tun muss irgendwo losgehen ja ich
habe mir allerdings gedacht dass ich das
hier so ein bisschen
denn der wie das hier gerade gemacht
dieses set ausgleich auf jeden fall neu
auf die sache jetzt allerdings was ich
mir gedacht habe dass ich hier einfach
das ganze durch erde er selbst sehr
fraglich jetzt wahrscheinlich machten
dass finden sind
der ein oder andere wird sich
wahrscheinlich schon denken weil ich
habe vorhin meinte wir brauchen den
glatten sandstein auf jeden fall und
zwar wollte ich hier vorne eine kleine
insel bauen so dumm dass jetzt
vielleicht klingen mag
allerdings habe ich das in meiner test
welt vorbereitet und das sagt richtig
rechtlichen als auch mit einer kleinen
insel hier im ort sehr einfach und es
passt auch zu dem generell der muss
leider weg es passt auch generell zu dem
ganzen vibe unseres projekts weil wir
haben ja auch so ein paar inseln rot
sehen und 2010 fort von daher habe ich
mir gedacht das könnte vielleicht ganz
gut passen den glatten sonnenstein nutze
jetzt einfach mal um hier außen rum so
ein bisschen was darzustellen als
wendland wäre da habe ich den garten
stellen relativ spät im projekt entdeckt
weil so hätte ich noch eine menge arbeit
bei unserer villiger in viel sparen
können wo ich quasi bei jedem sand
blog.de nicht gesetzt habe einfach
darunter ein erdloch gepackt habe das
gar keinen sinn gemacht hat
schlussendlich weiter seien sie von oben
genau so ist wie sand allerdings soll
das ganze so in etwa aussehen hier vorne
geht es dann quasi runter die sonne geht
auch schon wieder unter perfekt und hier
vorne soll das ganze dann quasi so
eingegrenzt sein allerdings als wenn das
hier so einen tunnel wer so richtig also
dass sie soll natürlich gras werden dann
soll dass sie alles so ein bisschen so
umgehen sagt hier vorne rein und so
weiter und so fort hier vorne bam bam
dann vielleicht noch hier so sagt und
dann quasi noch mal eine höhere dass man
quasi vielleicht sogar von hier gar
nicht mal so direkt rein geht sondern
irgendwie so und so dass sich so ein
bisschen andeutet willst du wie ich mal
vielleicht noch gar nicht hier vorne
hatte moment ich musste gar bleib so ein
bisschen überlegen
irgendwie so vielleicht in die
richtungen dann fängt das andere hier
irgendwie schon an passt es allerdings
auch nicht so guter machen wir hier noch
einen hin und dann baut man quasi ihren
kleinen
ja so ein kleinen berg und da reingeht
dann quasi die bahn als wird man mehr
oder weniger an so eine mine einfahren
allerdings fährt man nicht in die mine
sondern einfach auf die andere seite auf
unser fest plant dann wollte ich hier
auch noch nachher so ein bisschen den
pflanzen so ein paar bäume so dass das
quasi dann schlussendlich irgendwie so
aussieht so eine ahnung so in etwa er
hat man quasi hier rein und geht dann
quasi runter und hier ist jetzt halt
wasser jetzt halt nicht so schlau
gewesen ich gehe mal ganz schnell eben
schlafen da die sonne schon wieder
untergegangen ist einmal hierzu bitte
raus ist die sache ist wir brauchen
wirklich dieses behutsamkeit buch auf
unsere verzauberung und mich regt ist so
unfassbar auf dass ich mein verdammtes
gold spitzhacken behutsamkeit
arbeitsgerät einfach zerstört habe beim
dummen arbeiten
von daher probiere es jetzt nochmal mit
dem traden mit dem einen typen habe ich
zunächst einmal schauen wir hier in
unserem baumhaus ob die sachen fertig
sind die eisenbahnen sind fast fertig
das glas hier ist auf jeden fall fertig
hier das gold ist fertig und das glas
hier auch hast also dann können wir
gleich auf jeden fall mit dem du gehst
du wieder rein ins wasser perfekt er
hier vorne immer wieder party oder macht
der partie da sieht man nicht so richtig
nur
wir laufen jetzt allerdings fix mit
unserem bibliothekar der befindet sich
nämlich nicht hier das ist sagt
fischermeister das ist auch ein fischer
experte wochenende hier ist der
videothek perfekt also hier können wir
ganz gut hin gehen er hat rückstoß
verbrennung und stärke und mehr
tatsächlich nicht als nur namen steht er
doch immer um die gleichen sache nicht
erst gar nicht was das soll
ich brauche einfach dieses behutsamkeit
buch wäre es allerdings gar nicht mehr
genau wo ich ihnen dass diese putin
gestellt habe genau hierhin ich werde
das jetzt einfach mal abbauen und das
vor irgendwelche anderen villiger hier
setzen ich weiß nämlich nicht ob diese
hier die sind nämlich geselle er hier
ist meister haben die ja alle schon
beruf gibt sich irgendwer ist lehrling
gibt es neuling gibt sich irgendwie mit
dem ich noch nicht gehandelt habe ich
hab ich mit allen schon gehandelt zumal
er hier
er hat nicht so perfekt das heißt ich
könnte ihm theoretisch dass diese punkte
hin setzt das müsste der nun hier
hingehen
eine stunde später schreibt mir witze
nico keyser
so was haben
[Musik]
das verdammte meine erste wahl gibt es
behutsamkeit
so meine damen und herren ich habe mir
gerade noch habt ihr auch in der tat
gesehen ein bisschen brote kraft und ich
hatte ja noch ein bisschen bei mir und
ich habe noch nie eine diamant
spitzhacke gemacht die ich jetzt
zusammen mit dem behutsamkeit buch hier
in den amboss gepackt habe und ich würde
sagen dass sie die spitzhacke auch
benennen und zwar in den namen herbert
auf jeden fall nehme jetzt herbert und
bauen mit herbert ihn nun einen gras
block ab den wir dort hinten in
platzieren werden das ist nämlich ganz
neues denn dann wächst dort schneller
das ganze gras ist allerdings müssen
durfte das jetzt ja bauer
wenn man sich das hier wieder nicht so
gut aus aber es ist auf jeden fall ein
paar grad bürger mit wir können auch
einen von den gras blöcken fällt mir mal
ganz kurz auf dort hinten hin packen wo
wir aus versehen das lesepult ihm
platziert haben dann können wir direkt
bei den weg reparieren zack zack und
bumm so und dann würde ich allerdings
auch sagen dass wir ganz fix mal eben
kurz noch mal schlafen gehen
beziehungsweise was wir auch machen
können das ganz einfach
hier kommen die trauern gerade hier ne
enocean dann keine trauer sekunde mehr
für die verstorbene katze trikot pilz
für und die schildkröte wir können
einfach die blöcke die wir abbauen dann
immer mit erde erst mit erde ersetzen
das gleiche können dann beispielsweise
auch jetzt vorne machen und tag und sagt
um dann setzen wir da jetzt einfach eher
dahin die ich gerade nicht besitzer da
gehe ich mal ganz kurz noch mal kurz in
die kisten create was wir auch immer
noch als ziel haben ist er hier unten
einen bunker einzubauen die sache ist
allerdings dass ich mittlerweile soweit
gelernt habe dass ich so einen überfall
wir schon mal stattgefunden hat nicht
noch mal passieren lassen werde
ich werde nur ganz kurz die zeit nutzen
bis die sonne untergegangen dass hier
noch mal so ein bisschen zu machen also
hier vorne brauche ich auch nochmal ganz
kurzen park glück gehabt
man sieht richtig krass dass wir vorne
zu beginn hat die insel reparatur hat
und das spiel hinter diesen ganzen
sachen einfach dingen stehen noch diese
ganzen land blöcke stehen weil wir
einfach nur eine schicht erde drüber
gepackt damit von außen hat irgendwie
cool aus sagt er ich weiß hat die gute
alte zeit ist zwar so crazy sich dieses
projekt die generell entwickelt haben
das jetzt lässt steht das ist so krass
aber ich bin ganz ehrlich ich freue mich
auch mittlerweile extrem kreisstaffel 2
ich weiß nicht wie viel pause sein wird
zwischen staffel 1 ende also folge 100
und staffel 2 beginnen also staffel 2
folge eins will ich da so ein bisschen
pause machen werde ein paar wochen ein
paar monate oder das direkt im anschluss
sein wird ihr wisst ich lade man das
hoch worauf ich bock habe und auch die
letzten beiden videos auf einem kanal
waren ebay fails und mal wieder tipptopp
tuesday war ich einfach bock drauf hatte
und viele leute haben dann leider haben
wir unter diese videos in die kommentare
geschrieben luca was minecraft dislike
und das finde ich dann halt immer ein
bisschen traurig weil das macht mir das
ganze youtube dinge so ein bisschen
kaputt sag ich mal weil ich war schon
immer ein youtuber der irgendwelche
random sachen hochgeladen hatte ich weiß
noch früher habe ich gar hochgeladen hat
das gefühl jeder irgendwie schon vor
vier jahren gespielt dann hab ich's
hochgeladen einfach nicht ganz cool und
habe immer das gemacht worauf ich
eigentlich bock hatte auf dieser
plattform und das ist halt ein bisschen
kaputt gegangen internet wird seit welt
viele von mir erwarten dass ich halt
jetzt minecraft youtuber bin voll und
durch und das ist nur noch das hochladen
darf deswegen hoffe ich dass ihr das
respektiert dass ich mir da vielleicht
eine kleine pause damit minecraft
allerdings haben wir jetzt ein bisschen
er verteilt ein bisschen gras verteilten
wir sind schon hier vorne das wächst
schon drüber dahin merksatz drüber
ich setze ich auch mal so ein paar
fakten
dann wächst das immer noch mal ein
bisschen schneller wenn man hier ein
bisschen licht am start ist also das
sollte auf jeden fall klappen was sich
allerdings jetzt auch mal ganz kurz
holen werde ist eine sache die ich gar
nicht mehr habe glaub' ich und zwar
knochen wenn ich benötige auch
knochenmehl für die insel da hinten denn
ich hab mir gedacht da kommen auch noch
zwei bäume drauf da möchte auch ein
bisschen gras drauf setzen und dann ist
das quasi so der eingang in den tunnel
und sieht ein bisschen besser aus wenn
dieser glaskasten man geht einfach
runter von daher ist schaue ich mal ganz
kurz ob ich auch irgendwo knochen habe
ich glaube ich hab leider alles zu
knochen mehr verarbeitet weil ich das da
vorne hin machen wollte
die sache ist allerdings ist er
vielleicht noch in irgendeiner anderen
kiste fündig werden also hier ist auf
jeden fall nichts
hier ist leider auch nichts haben wir
hier was bei den drobny wir haben
tatsächlich keine knochen mehr das heißt
ich muss mich noch mal zu der unserer
falle bewegen jedoch kann ich vorher
mich schon mal um ein zwei andere sachen
kümmern denn wo waren sie denn jetzt die
meeresbucht ich glaube hier fordern
genau die meeres guten hier muss ich auf
jeden fall mitnehmen und das glas habe
ich und ich brauch noch eine menge
bruchsteine habe ich nämlich hier war es
hier was ihr wisst ihr was sollte auf
jeden fall ausreichen dann kann ich
nämlich weil ja unserem opfer direkt
neben dem unterwasser tunnel ist die mob
falle schon mal so ein bisschen
aktivieren dadurch dass ich hier ein
bisschen arbeiten bin und da euch noch
ein ersatzpilot die meeres gruppen habe
ich übrigens mitgenommen weil ich das
hier unter wasser alles ein bisschen
beleuchten wollte da hinten also film ab
[Musik]
so freunde ich habe das ganze hier so
vorne schon mal angerichtet hier vorne
habe ich ein paar meeres gurken
hingesetzt da hinten so dass es jetzt
ein bisschen mehr beleuchtet ist hier
vorne kann ich auch ein paar mehr
hinsetzen allerdings wollte ich jetzt
auch nicht hier im umkreis irgendwelche
meeres gurken abbauen so dass sich
beispielsweise der hinweg nehmen und
hier hinsetzen so das ist da hinten
wieder dunkel
also müssen wir auch noch eine
meereskunde farming tour gehen demnächst
auch stadt der porta in china unter
wasser auf jeden fall ist das die vorne
jetzt unser tunnel so ein bisschen hier
vorne kommen dann natürlich noch das
glas hin
da habe ich allerdings auch eine menge
sex mit am start wir müssen allerdings
wahrscheinlich demnächst nochmal in die
wüste gehen hin zum wüsten dorfen noch
ein bisschen mehr glas mitnehmen die
sache ist allerdings dass sie ja schon
wieder seht dass die sonne untergeht von
daher werde ich die zeit jetzt einfach
mal nutzen und hier vorne in meine
skelett farben gehen da wird jetzt denke
ich nicht allzu viel gespannt sein wenn
überhaupt irgendwas gespannt sein sollte
weil ich gar nicht weiß ob die reagiert
haben als ich da von einem unterwasser
tunnel gearbeitet habe die sache ist
allerdings wir haben gar keinen vom
staat
wir haben allerdings noch 64 wenn ich
sogar mehr knochenmehl hier am start den
kann ich auch mal ganz kurz töten daraus
dass es perfekt dass ich das letzte mal
fand die mitgenommen haben daraus kann
ich mir nämlich direkt dann auch mal
knochen mir machen was ich gerade schon
habe und dass hinten auf unserer kleinen
insel platzieren denn wir müssen heute
ja auch noch eine zweite insel bauen und
dafür benötigen wir auch noch eine menge
knochen mir um da so ein bisschen leben
reinzukriegen ein bisschen verbuchten es
mit mit dem gras mit denen nachts
nee du wir sind blind wir schwimmen
jetzt mal wieder ganz fix zurück zu
unserer insel hier und werden auch schon
direkt natürlich begrüßt von zwei
hübschen skeletten sack und pack der
eine ist tot und der andere auch tot
jetzt müssen wir ganz schnell mal eben
schwarzen mini midi schnell hoch ich
will einfach nur keinen creeper hier am
start haben das wird mir schon
ausreichend also mein ganzes leben
schlafengehen sollte allerdings nehme
ich alles klappt perfekt und dann können
wir uns jetzt auch direkt darauf
konzentrieren das wird noch mal ganz
kurz die sachen holen für die zweite
insel bevor wir uns allerdings um die
zweite insel kümmern schauen wir uns
erstmal dass wir vorne an denn das ist
alles tatsächlich schon gewachsen mit
dem ganzen gras von daher kann die
fackeln ja auch entfernen und ich werde
jetzt mal hier beispielsweise einen baum
hinsetzen dafür jetzt einfach mal hier
so ein bisschen knochen wir nehmen das
klappt nicht perfekt
hier klappt auf jeden fall dann amerika
vorne einen baum und wir können
beispielsweise auch nochmal hier einen
draufsetzen ich hofft man dass das jetzt
auch klappt perfekt haben wir hier zwei
sich die bäumchen auf jeden fall dann
gehen wir hier drauf hier drauf jeder
auf hier drauf hier drauf hier drauf und
nochmal hier drauf dann habe ich auf
jeden fall solistin verbucht hatten es
am start und wenn wir uns das ganze von
weiter weg angucken seht ihr auch schon
das ganze sieht ein bisschen mehr nach
einer kleinen wirklich sehr selten
hinaus jedoch schon ich hab mich in der
einzige baum mitgenommen denn die könnte
ich beispielsweise hier hinsetzen in der
laterne dann sieht wirklich so aus als
würden wir hier irgendwie eine mine
reinfahren und ich selbst auch noch mal
eine auf der anderen seite das wenn man
zurückkehrt dass man schon an der
oberfläche oder von untergrund der kennt
okay wir sind gleich klar dass hier auch
ein bisschen später aus wenn man jetzt
natürlich runter geht haben wir alles
easy bleibt darauf stellen wir nutzen
jetzt allerdings unsere schienen um das
ganze wieder so ein bisschen weiter
runter zu setzen das muss ich dich mal
ganz kurz doch eben entfernen und dann
gehts quasi hier runter hier vorne haben
jetzt das was müssen demnächst noch mal
weg machen
allerdings will ich erstmal den tunnel
komplett zu ende bauen also dass wir
schon allein irgendwie raus kommen dann
kommt man halt hochfährt dann hier quasi
wieder rein in unsere welt mit den
ganzen kleinen inselchen und ja mit an
diese kleine insel hier vorne am start
ist auf jeden fall selbst suite wir
müssen uns jetzt allerdings darum
kümmern dass wir hinten auch noch eine
insel hinkriegen ich werde jedoch erst
mal ganz kurz zu der insel da vorne hin
schwimmen denn ich habe ja meine
behutsamkeit spitzhacke dabei um mir
noch mal ganz kurz ein paar gras blöcke
zu krallen neuen grasfläche sollten da
auf jeden fall ausreichen und jetzt gehe
ich hier ganz kurz hoch und da das ja
hier vorne dann runter geht würde ich
auch sagen dass wir dem ganzen hier auch
so ein bisschen vor aufgeben wir können
das natürlich die ganze zeit nachher
noch verändern allerdings hat mir da
vorne glaube ich auch drei oder vier
blöcke vorlauf bis es dann so richtig
runter geht perfekt er sieht extrem
scheiße aus von daher euch mal eine ganz
kurze time lab so wie ich hier auch ganz
kurz eben die insel bauer
[Musik]
so die zweite insel hier ist jetzt auch
fertig habe die relativ wenig gebaut wie
die andere insel hier vorne habe ich
schon eine laterne hingesetzt auf eine
steinmauer und das gleiche werde ich
jetzt auch noch hier vorne eben machen
setzt sich dann beispielsweise hier auf
die ecke so drauf beziehungsweise
vielleicht sogar auswendig hier so drin
sitzt also noch mal ganz kurz weg sagt
die auf jeden fall besser aus dass die
erzieherin ist jetzt müssen wir ganz
kurz warten dass das gras so ein
bisschen drüber gewachsen ist dann kann
ich meinen knochenmehl nehmen und hier
vorne alles so ein bisschen verrückt
machen kann ich allerdings schon ein
bisschen anfangen so dass ihr wissen in
welche richtung es gehen soll
sowas habe ich allerdings auch nur noch
vier knochen mir von erwarte ich noch
mal eben ganz kurz und jetzt sehe ich
auf jeden fall schon da hinten ist quasi
eine insel man wird gar nichts mehr
hören man denkt das ist eigentlich in
der insel wie meines bohrinsel dahin
beziehung also das ist ja eigentlich
meine spawn insel wo der leuchtturm
draufsteht
allerdings ist die jetzt künstlich von
mir erstellt worden genauso wie diese
insel hier und hier vorne fährt man dann
quasi rein beziehungsweise raus mit dem
kart und dann muss es hier natürlich
auch runtergehen ich idiot oder ich hab
kommt herein geschossen
[Musik]
jetzt die inseln oder diese treppe hier
leute freaks hier
[Musik]
während ich im bett lag während ich im
verdammten bett lag glas kaputt sand
kaputt
[Musik]
so meine damen und herren wir bereits
unschwer erkennen könnte habe ich mich
dazu entschieden weil die insel jetzt
schon so perfekt schön steht einfach die
treppe ein bisschen rum zu verschieben
das war jetzt ein bisschen mühsam unter
wasser allerdings hat es geklappt und
die treppe geht jetzt perfekt hier
runter grenzt hier an und geht dann da
ganz hinten wieder hoch und hier
benötigen wir halt noch ein bisschen
glas ich würde sagen 26 benötigen wir
auf jeden fall noch schienen usw habe
ich alles die sache ist allerdings dass
wir für den ganzen sand ja definitiv
noch mal an unseren küsten dorf hinten
müssen die sonne geht dahinter auch
schon wieder unter deswegen stehe ich
jetzt mal ganz kurz sie wieder zurück
zur anderen seite und gehe dann auch
schlafen was dann auch das ende der
heutigen folge darstellen wird meine
lieben freunde der tunnel ist noch nicht
perfekt ganz fertig allerdings benötigen
wir dafür ja auch noch die schwämme und
dafür müssen wir dann noch mal hinten in
das ozean monument und zwar das müssen
wir demnächst auf jeden fall auch noch
machen die sache ist allerdings dass der
tunnel mehr oder weniger erstmal steht
also geht auf jeden fall hier vorne
langen dort hinten durch und dann geht
er dorthin wieder hoch ich finde die
lösung auch eigentlich ganz cool dass
wir dann hier vorne so eine kleine insel
haben weil das macht so ein bisschen
anschluss zu dir ist ein auge drauf das
macht ein bisschen anschluss zu unseren
ganzen inselgruppen da hinten dann haben
wir vorne hin sondern gibt arbeiter hier
dann der tunnel dann wieder hier
ich lege mich jetzt allerdings mal ganz
gut schlafe ich leg mich bestimmt nicht
noch mal hier rechts an meine villa
schlafen wo diese blöde creeper vorhin
explodiert ist zwar wirklich der folge
wieder alles dabei war wir hatten
zombies werten creeper wir haben
bisschen was gebaut werden fails mit am
start wir hatten time labs es allerdings
keine spannung also wenn ihr bock habt
irgendwann demnächst dass ich mal wieder
eine höhle gier schreibt sie gerne in
die kommentare wenn die generell ideen
vorschläge habt sachen die ich noch
bauen soll dezentral in unserer los
lukas welt hier hinten dann schreibt man
auch gerne in die kommentare wenn es
euch gefallen hat das kann einen daumen
hoch und ein video hier da abonniert nur
ein kanal und klickt auf die glocke wenn
der neue videos nicht verpassen weil ich
habe so viel saba grad im mund dings
einmal dann runterzuschlucken naja ich
warte jetzt bis dahin die sonne
untergegangen ist endlich schlafen und
dann sehen wir uns übermorgen wieder bei
einem anderen video nicht minecraft das
kommt wieder ersten vier tagen ich hoffe
ihr versteht das wir sehen uns
[Musik]